[Music]
i'm very pleased to be joined now by the
ranking member on the house judiciary
committee now very shortly i'm expecting
him to be the chairman of the house
judiciary committee
the republicans are looking pretty good
for 2022 but there's a long way to go i
am joined by none other than
congressman jim jordan author of the new
book do what you said
you would do one of the things that jim
jordan said he would do is come here to
nashville to be on the show congressman
thank you for being here thank you thank
you for having me michael and thank you
for all you do for
for the cause of freedom we uh we
appreciate it well that's that's very
kind i'm so glad that you could be here
because uh freedom is under threat the
freedom i'm not just talking about pie
in the sky freedom
i'm not even talking about economic
freedom we hear a lot about that yeah
i'm talking about the freedom to
raise your own kids yep and you have
been calling out the attorney general
merrick garland on this merrick garland
said i have not labeled parents
white supremacist domestic terrorists
for for wanting to stop crazy gender and
race theories in their schools
but a whistleblower
seems to have thrown that story upside
down right did the attorney general lie
yeah he said that on on october 21st and
just so happened when he said that the
day before
uh the head of the counter-terrorism
division at the fbi so not just anybody
at the fbi the head of the
counterterrorism division has sent out
an email to fbi agents around the
country saying do what merit garland
said that he wasn't doing just 24 hours
later to actually put a threat tag on
parents on people moms and dads showing
up at school board meetings i mean they
were showing up to protest uh this this
crazy racist hate america curriculum um
so yeah i think he misled the committee
we've asked for him to come back
and he should because he's got to answer
some i think pretty well here's one
question i think the first question you
ask him is how many
what's the number
how many parents have the tag or the
label and
when i first saw our our staff at the
district committee showed me the
the correspondence from the
whistleblower and the and the email that
went out
when i first saw it i thought the first
thing that came to mind is this is what
the irs did 10 years ago 10 12 years ago
when they had the bolo list be on the
lookout for these people these types of
groups saying using terms like freedom
and patriot and imagine that all those
terrible yeah so this is this is just
another example of of weaponizing the
government to go after people with a
different political uh
belief then than what what the left has
in the government the creepiest part of
this to me well there are many creepy
parts i don't want to make that claim
but one of the creepiest parts is that
these parents who show up and say we
don't want critical race theory in
schools we don't want radical gender
theory in schools they are labeled by
the federal government domestic
terrorists or whatever
it's not as though they're being charged
with a crime it's not as though they're
going to get to have their day in court
they're just
having that label put on them and in
many cases they won't even know it yeah
no that that that's
your and it's the federal government i
mean it shouldn't be anybody in
government doing it but the idea the big
federal government's coming in and if
there is some kind of violence or
something happen to school well then the
local government local sheriff's local
police they can they should handle
that's how it's supposed to work in our
in our federal constitutional system but
when you have the fbi doing this here's
the other thing i think as i look at the
timeline on this remember the letter
comes from the school board association
on september 29th four days later the
letter asks for it talks about parents
talks about the patriot act and
asked the biden administration to go
after these moms and dads five days
later merrick garland the attorney
general united states issues a
memorandum which does just that puts in
place task force in all 94 u.s judicial
districts the u.s attorney districts
around the country and and then we go
through this and mayor gardner comes
testify but we now have learned that
through it's been reported that the
white house was working with the school
board association right before the
letter was ever sent so i don't think
this was actually the school board
association
initiating this i think it came from the
government and i think they just used
the letter as the pretext to do this to
go after they didn't like the parents
were showing up protesting they said
we're going to stop it and we're going
to stop it by by this chilling impact of
the attorney general of the united
states issuing a memo that says we're
going to treat parents as a given this
this label of a of a terrorist tag a
threat tag
the one thing they didn't bargain for
though moms and dads said like heck you
are these are my kids i mean i always
said
no no lobbyist no bureaucrat no
government official will ever beat a mom
on a mission and these moms said we're
not going to tolerate this and moms and
dads stood up and that's what they
didn't expect and it was so much so that
the day less than 24 hours after merrick
garland testifies
the agency that this left-wing political
group they issue an apology for the
initial letter i've never you you follow
politics i've been in politics a long
time i have never seen that happen 24
hours later oh we and here's the
language we regret and apologize for the
letter wow that's so they didn't bargain
for that the bite administration i think
though so it didn't go from school
boards association to the government i
think that went the other way right
that's the scary part now do you think
that this
movement has legs because i think you're
totally right i think that the
government and the the democrats and the
liberal establishment broadly saw this
education issue as a big threat it just
cost them a governorship in virginia
they saw parents of all stripes of all
shapes of all colors showing up and
saying we're going to protect our kids
we have the right to raise our kids not
you terry mcauliffe not you joe biden
it seems to me this is the first issue
driven grassroots movement on the right
yeah since the tea party you had the tea
party now you have the crt party if
you're part of the lame time
do you think that this
just wins this virginia maybe it helps a
little in jersey and it fizzles or does
this movement about education from the
right have like no it has legs and you
ask the question because you know it has
legs or you believe it you believe the
same thing i do um it's funny you say
that because
the october 21st few weeks ago when
merrick garden testified i gave my
opening statement you know how these
committee things work jerry nadler the
chairman gives the opening statement
then the top republican opening
statement at the end of my opening
statement i said mr attorney general i
think this memo
i think this was the last straw
i think this is a catalyst for a great
reawakening kind of revival type mindset
in this country for freedom for for
judeo-christian principles and values
and i think that's catching on i i
really do and then of course it was a
few weeks later as you point out where
where the voters in in virginia said
time out we're gonna we're gonna make
glenn younk in the next governor of our
state because we don't like where this
is going
and it happened on top of what we've
been through over the last year where
frankly every single right we enjoy as
americans under the first amendment has
been assaulted by the left and so with
that that kind of in that framework they
now find out and now they're gonna now
they're gonna label us terrorists and
they're coming after they think they're
smarter than we are as moms and dads
about our kids right no not time out to
that so i think it is gonna grow i think
it really is even this word education
you know we think of it as just reading
writing and arithmetic yeah education
means
raising a kid i mean that's the root of
the word and and so it's about a lot
more than that and
you know to your observation here that a
lot of this is about
losing christianity or christian
morality losing the regular old
patriotism that we used to have now
we're being taught all the opposite of
that in schools but there's obviously a
moral component there's obviously a
religious component if you teach a kid
we hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men are created equal
and endowed by their creator with
certain unalienable rights that's a
religious or a statement it's something
that that we're teaching for a long time
republicans said
we don't want to touch it yeah we don't
want to touch the culture issues we
don't want to touch anything about
religion or morality we're just we're
going to cut taxes and that's that yeah
obviously it hasn't served us very well
um do you see the republican party
getting behind this kind of i do i do i
i i really do because i mean think about
this uh you go to any major urban uh
public school district in the country
and and the graduation rate is some
ridiculously low percentage kids reading
at grade level third graders in detroit
reading at grade level is 30 i'm just
making a number but we know it's bad 30
40
and and so this is happening in all
kinds of urban public schools and now
some other schools around the country
and what what are democrats say well
here's our answer uh we're gonna we're
gonna make your kid wear a mask all day
at school we're gonna teach them
critical race theory we're gonna tell
them that their country stinks and and
meanwhile parents are saying well i
don't like all that and i'd also like
you to teach them to read and write and
learn the basics right so
if if you're i think what we should be
saying is do not voters out there do not
vote for anyone who's not for school
choice don't vote for anyone who doesn't
say moms and dads should determine
what's best for their kids education and
if you got a candidate running for
office and they're not for that don't
help them and
work against them or find a candidate to
run against them that's that's how we
have to do it and i think that will
catch on we've got much more with
congressman jordan coming up but first
legacy box is very simple and it is very
simply the best way to preserve your
past so i'm sure you got a bunch of
stuff you got a bunch of valuable stuff
and if some of it gets destroyed in a
flood or a fire or just with the
degradations of time it's no big deal
you'll just replace them but some of
your stuff you can't replace like your
photos like your home movies like those
cassettes
don't let them degrade over time send
them into legacy box they will be hand
digitized and you will get back not only
the physical media but you'll also get a
thumb drive or a dvd or access to the
cloud where you can have those memories
digitally preserved forever this is one
of the most important investments that
you can possibly make in your family and
in those cherished memories i love a
legacy box they really helped me out to
save some photos that i thought were
gone forever and the physical photos
probably will be gone not too long from
now but the digital copy will be there
forever so head on over to legacybox.com
knowles save an unbelievable 65
with limited quantities ready to ship
this deal is going to go fast go to
legacybox.com
knowlescanwles that is legacybox.com
knowles for 65 off
you know i i saw the day after youncan's
victory in virginia i saw some i won't
name names but some members of
republican leadership they said this was
a victory against socialism that was the
message and i thought look i hate
socialism socialism is evil yeah
this had nothing to do with social
rights
terry mcauliffe is a regular crooked
corporate democrat he's not shea guevara
you know this is a clinton democrat he's
a clinton democrat and i i just think
if
if we just run against socialism
we're gonna have the same old coalition
we always say yeah but if we can somehow
convince
whole swats of people that the democrats
are indoctrinating your kids with a
bunch of nonsense that's gonna screw
them up for life yeah which is obviously
happen we got the receipts for that yeah
maybe we have a chance into 2020 right
maybe 2024. yeah i mean the american
people are smart people they when the
american people have common sense and i
think they've now seen the big picture
remember the guy who's in the white
house he campaigned on i'm not bernie
sanders right he campaigned on i'm
scranton joe i'm moderate joe i'm middle
class joe and you know it wasn't true
but that's that's what he that's what he
sold to the american people and he got
in office and what did he do the very
first day signed all those executive
orders one of those was getting rid of
the 1776 commissioners this this
commission that says let's focus on
american history and what a great
country we have the great not perfect
but the greatest nation ever built on a
principle as you said in the declaration
of independence endowed by our creator
uh with these inalienable rights so uh
he changed that on day one and has been
bernie sanders plus
yeah since day one and that's not how he
that's not how he marketed himself to
the to the country and in that context
and then we see what every policy area
they've touched has been a disaster
the border inflation tax policy you name
it it's
energy policy and now oh and now you're
going to come after moms and dads
that in that context the voters are
saying time no way are we going to
tolerate that so i do think it's it's
growing and this education issue is kind
of the issue that i think kind of
brought it all together in that in that
larger framework so polls are looking
good
right now joe biden is what 37 38
percent kamala harris is 28
dick cheney after the iraq war and after
shooting a guy in the face was 30. he
was doing better than kamala harris is
today harry i remember he said that i've
shot harry yeah and he was right exactly
yeah and he was still polling higher so
they're they're really not looking good
let's say the republicans take back the
majority in the house 2022 what's the
first thing you do
uh the first thing we do is pat now we
won't be able to make law because joe
biden's going to be able to beat
everything first thing we do in the
judiciary committee yeah which uh lord
willing i'll all have the the chance to
chair is we passed this uh section 230.
uh we we get rid of the liability
protection for big tech who is centering
uh censoring um folks like you and i
yeah um so that's that's the first piece
of legislation it won't become law but
it's important to let the the country
know we're we're doing everything we can
well
this is what aoc did with the green new
deal yeah put it out there and everyone
laughed about it and she was persistent
persistent persistent now it's a
mainstream idea might become law right i
mean that's how politics works in
america you frame it up and then you
have a big presidential election and if
one party gets control of government
they get to they get to push the the
stuff that they campaign on they get to
do what they said they were going to do
right um and i do think it's going to
happen by the way i do think
you hate to you don't want to be
overconfident we got to work hard but i
do think republicans are going to take
it back i mean the polling two weeks ago
showed um
they asked the right track wrong track
question 71 percent of our fellow
citizens
think the country's on the wrong track
i mean when i first heard that i
actually said i want to meet the 29
percent i want to meet the 29 who think
we're on the right track there hasn't
been anything go well in the last 10
months so i do think it's it's shaping
up as a win for us
if we win
what we have to do is undo as much as we
can of the by division it'll be tough
because he's still going to be in in the
white house but we have to frame it up
and i yesterday had a debate on the
house floor with jim mcgovern democrat
chair of the rules committee and he says
republicans blame uh joe biden for
everything never tell us what they're
for and it made me mad so i got i spoke
once i got back up and spoke again i
said i'll tell you what we're for we're
actually for a secure border we're
actually which we had under president
trump uh i'll tell you i'll tell you
what before we're actually for stable
prices which we had under president
trump uh well i'll tell you what we're
for wages going up real wage is going up
like we had just 10 months ago i'm for
energy independence like we had 10
months ago i'm for a doj
that doesn't go after its citizens
doesn't use the awesome power of the fbi
to go after its citizens i'm for a doj
that doesn't pay illegal immigrants 450
000 for coming in or breaking the law
and coming into our country so
that that's what we have to to
demonstrate to the american people um
if we're given the the chance to lead
the congress you know i'm glad you
brought up all of those specific
policies because
we think oh nothing really changes it's
not a big deal both sides always get
hyperbolic about how the other side is
the cause of all all evil
under trump real wages increased for the
first time in a very long time under
trump at least the first part of his
presidency
the problems at the border really did
diminish considerably sure did
under trump you actually did have
manufacturing confidence at record highs
under trump you know you had
unemployment at all-time lows or very
nearly all-time lows
and then it all changed and things can
change very quickly and people are
seeing that at the gas pump and they're
seeing that yeah go to go out
thanksgiving shopping so one of the
zanier ideas that has been floated
is that if the republicans retake the
house
the speaker of the house does not need
to be a member of congress speaker could
be for instance a brash billionaire
from new york who now resides in florida
yeah
what do you think the likelihood of that
i think he's going to run for president
i want him to i've said it i'm for him
i'm for him 110
no president in my lifetime
has done more of what he said he would
do than president trump and he did it
with everyone against him that whole
town every single democrat i mean
adamantly
crazy against him we all know uh
everyone in the mainstream press was
against him everyone in the bureaucracy
which is the real problem uh was against
him uh and a bunch of republicans and
yet in spite of that he said he would
cut taxes he did he said he'd reduce
regulations he did he said he would have
the best economy we did he said he'd
stand up to china he did he said he
built the bosses yeah
said he built the wall he did said he
would get out of that crazy iran deal he
did said he put the embassy in jerusalem
he did and a bunch of other things and
i'm like
i'll take a guy like that who actually
kept when he first got to the white
house i was in the in the west wing with
mark meadows and i we were there several
times but early on they had a big white
board
and they had written out every campaign
problem every single one
and they were literally checking it off
that's leadership that that's that's
what you want in our country and frankly
i think there's a yearning for now i had
a lady in a and uh she was an older lady
it was kind of like a quasi town hall in
a little town in our in the fourth
district of ohio
and uh she's probably mid 70s
and she started talking about what what
you're just saying how
how crazy it's gotten in 10 months yeah
and her eyes started i mean she they
started to glass up as she was thinking
because she loves the country like we
all do like president trump does
and she sees what's happening and so
that's what's so encouraging about what
we're seeing what we saw happen in
virginia what courage is contagious it's
a mom at a school board meeting and then
the next meeting it's five moms and a
few dads and then pretty soon it's
pretty soon people are it's the chicago
police union saying you know what
the vaccine should be a choice this this
virus is serious you want to get a
vaccine grade but it's it's freedom i
mean it's contagious and you're you're
going to see that spread i think and
it's going to it's going to mean i think
a way potentially a wave election in 22.
there is a whole lot more that we have
with congressman jordan coming up but
before we get to that i absolutely love
my x-chair this chair not only is it
extremely comfortable not only is it
extremely ergonomic it is probably the
coolest looking piece of furniture that
we've got around here okay what makes
the x chair the world's greatest office
chair well
maybe it's the patented dynamic variable
lumbar support or the fact that you can
add lmax technology with four massage
options and the ability to warm or cool
your back you can do that in your office
yeah i just get a massage whenever i
want one it's great sounds kind of saucy
but it's totally above board because
it's from your ex chair now is the
perfect time to purchase next year and
why now because now is the only time
that extra goes on sale all year
right now only on black friday and cyber
monday and now that weekend that's when
you can get these deals you can save up
to 500 bucks on x chair four days only
black friday to cyber monday go to
xchairknowles.com that is the letter x
chair
canadawles.com x chair has a 30 day
guarantee of complete comfort you can
finance your purchase for as little as
25 bucks a month go to externals.com
save up to 500 bucks xchairnoles.com
i feel uncomfortable by how optimistic
you are right now as a conservative i i
feel odd when people are optimistic
but it does seem like there are signs of
hope
however we you know
just a few months ago now i guess more
like a year ago
a lot of americans didn't have faith in
the presidential election
four years before that a lot of other
americans didn't have faith in the
presidential election
but at least 16 years before that a lot
of americans didn't have faith in the
presidential election terry mcauliffe
actually still doesn't accept the
results of the 2000 presidential
election or the georgia gubernatorial
election so
there was the kyle rittenhouse verdict
that just came out a lot of americans
don't have faith in the justice system i
think that gives us a little glimmer of
hope for the justices
but but people's faith in these
institutions and in the rule of law
has really broken down recently and so
do you do you think that there is a
glimmer of hope to to restore not just
not just to win an election but to
restore confidence in the institutions
or are things always darkest before they
go pitching no well i mean a lot of
times it gets it looks pretty bad until
until it gets better
uh i would say a couple of things um
one americans are optimistic by nature
we're americans
i think it's in our dna you know it's
like
you know some people even you know kind
of push that that whole idea that maybe
there's some truth to it because you
think about the folks who came here they
told them in europe you got to practice
your faith a certain way and they said
no we don't and we're willing to get on
a ship risk it all and come to this
place called america where we can do it
the way we think the good lord wants us
to and that's been the american
americans hate being told what to do
yeah we just that's just who we are so i
do feel like there's a i do feel
optimistic because it's first of all
america someone once said that um
in this country
every third generations had to do
something big
the founders
did something amazing when they started
this experiment we in freedom we call
america three generations later lincoln
and
held the country together got rid of the
evil of slavery three generations later
the greatest generation defeated the
evil of of nazi germany and imperial
japan and here we are three generations
later and and it's the left and it's the
people who want to destroy the
constitution and are on this accelerated
march to uh
to communism so
but we'll we'll i feel optimistic i i
really do uh i think
i think americans get it i'm encouraged
i've said it now a couple times and you
reference it as what happened in
virginia i think it's going to build i i
really do and the written house decision
is a is a in my mind just a god bless
america kind i mean it's a victory for
due process for our system of justice
for the second amendment i mean if that
wasn't self-defense i don't know what
was and the jury
with all the
the intimidation factors that were
swirling around that courthouse in
kenosha made the right decision
that's great and i think i think
americans are like
inspired by that and proud of how the
system worked um how our
due process and everything worked for
um this situation so yeah i'm encouraged
with the
mike pence vice president used to tell
us in the house he'd said uh i'm a
conservative and i'm not mad about it
right they're like we might as well we
should be the happy warriors because we
for goodness sake we live in america
right remember i'm just gonna say my
background is wrestling i've traveled to
the soviet union and wrestling back in
the 80s yeah go to places like that you
think the good lord you live here and
and we're i think in the long run we're
going to get through this forget about
soviet union i go to italy for a week
get me out of here these people don't
even know how to conduct business here
i think there's there's a lot to that
and obviously a conservative almost in
his very nature
is going to be a little happier with the
way things are you know we're a little
maybe better adjusted to things we're
not out screaming with crazy colored
hair and throwing molotov cocktails so
so that's all all great
and it gets to something you mentioned
right at the top and i guess it's really
what we're all talking about here
freedom yeah you know
from what i'm seeing and you're seeing
it much more closely in in washington
it seems like the right
is
coming to terms a little bit with
freedom in a way that we haven't in
recent decades you know
for the left freedom is do whatever you
want whenever you want to do it right if
it feels good do it right for the right
that was never really
what freedom was right you know the
founding fathers said liberty cannot be
abused to licentiousness john adams
constitution is built for moral and
religious people
and and all of a sudden you're you're
starting to see the right kind of crack
out of that libertine language and
they're saying actually no we're going
to say no to critical race theory in
schools yep it's going to limit your
freedom in a certain some kind of
freedom but not really it's actually
going to expand your no we're going to
say no
to this
desiccated degraded culture and we're
going to say yes to the great point the
higher constraints of liberty i mean do
you do you see that message
resonating or do people just want to do
whatever they want well human nature is
such that you want to do whatever you
want but you're right real freedom real
freedom flows from discipline and we all
fall short that's why you know that's
why we we need a savior uh so we all
fall short and certainly i do but but
true freedom is built on on discipline
and self-discipline because if you're
disciplined to do things right it gives
you more opportunity greater greater
ability to chase your goals and dreams
and so
that's the understanding that that that
we need to uh
we need to have so yeah i do think
that's the case i also think though i
would add one thing to your description
of the left they're not only for doing
anything they're for doing anything as
long as you don't criticize me too right
so it used to be you could have a debate
this is this is this to me this is the
scariest thing happening
is the attack on the first amendment
because it used to be i i i talk about
this in the book dennis kucinich is a
friend of mine dennis kucinich is an old
school liberal he believes in the first
amendment and dennis dennis showed up at
our oldest daughter's uh wedding i mean
he's a he's a friend i don't agree with
him he's a crazy lefty he doesn't agree
with me but he believes in the first
amendment have a debate make your best
argument let's see who wins then we'll
move on to the next issue and have that
debate and see how it plays out today's
left is different today's left is if you
don't agree with me you're not allowed
to talk right and if you try
i'm going to call you a racist and we're
going to try to cancel you and america
said no you're not we've had it we're
sick of the
the terms call us deplorable calmness
racist calling us those you know
hillbillies and fly over country
that doesn't work any like forget it you
can call that i've been called every
name you can imagine i know you have to
you go to college campuses which is
really brave so
we're tired of that we're going to stand
up and speak the truth and we're going
to defend the first amendment because
over the last year
every single right we enjoy as americans
under the first amendment has been
assaulted and i think americans have had
it your right to your right to uh
practice your faith your right to
assemble your right to petition your
government freedom of the press free
every freedom of speech everyone's been
attacked there are places in america
today a full congregation still can't
meet on a sunday morning right well in
america right it's it's it's so i think
that's that's the unifying one of the
unifying uh
themes for conservatives and for making
making our conservative movement even
bigger but congressman what the left
will tell you
and frankly what i think some of the
squishes even on the right will tell you
is
a lot of the incursions into free speech
are not being pushed by the government
exactly
when facebook and twitter and youtube
kick you off even if they kick off the
duly elected sitting president of the
united states well they're they're
private businesses yeah freedom demands
that we let mark zuckerberg and hipster
rasputin jack dorsey and all the rest of
them
control the speech in our republic go
build your own google yeah basically
right well why why doesn't that argument
hold up yeah because i mean well first
of all this is why one the one bill we
talked about earlier this is why you got
to take away their liability protection
second i one of the pieces of
legislation we're
looking at putting together now again
we'd have to have a republican majority
and republican president but is an
expedited way to get these anti-trust
issues to the supreme court justice
thomas as indicated seems to me he's
pretty clearly indicating he wants to
deal with this issue um so we need to
get that to the to the court in a in a
much much quicker fashion than
traditionally happens with any trust
issues so i think those are on the
legislative side but you're right when
you got someone this big having this
much influence i mean
it was uh
i think i write about this too but it
was like three years ago uh
in the summer i'm i'm literally walking
in in in the rayburn office building and
i get a call from matt gates
and he and all he didn't say hello he
just
typical matt he's always he's got 80d
like like you and i got but he goes jim
twitter is shadow banning us and you
know i'm you matt's young like you guys
and i was like uh matt that sounds
terrible but what's white shadow go on
yeah yeah
explained it to me and it turned out
they were and they were think about they
were shadow banning four members of
congress gates
meadows
nunes jordan i'm like oh interesting
four
and uh you know 435 members in the house
100
senators 535 only four
and jack dorsey said uh uh well it was
just a glitch in their algorithm and i'm
like yeah i was being interviewed and i
said
glitch in your algorithm what did you
put in the algorithm the names gates
meadows jordan i mean like a monkey on a
on a typewriter writing shakespeare yes
i guess it could happen maybe maybe it
was just chant uh
so yeah this is this is what and as the
example you point out the ayatollah can
tweet but president trump can't like
give me a break so americans see it um
and we're looking at a different all
different you know alternative platforms
all that's good but in the end congress
is going to have to act and i think
those those two avenues uh certainly are
where we should start and it may have to
be more it's it's in a way ironic though
maybe not that
conservatives used to be on the side of
the big tech before they were really
really big
because the new media gave conservatives
an opportunity to break through the
gatekeepers of the old media but they
didn't like that very much and
especially after 2016 they hated it so
they clamped down on us and it i guess
exactly right it just seems like a
matter of priorities of course we want
flourishing free enterprise we want
entrepreneurship we want all these
things
not at the expense of our most basic
political rights to speak if sundar
pichai at google is shutting me up yeah
it doesn't make me feel better that he
doesn't technically work for the
government right i need my right to be
able to speak and and control my own
government yeah because that's the most
fundamental liberty we have i tell
people
it's even more important than your right
to practice your faith because if you
can't talk
how can you practice your faith how can
you share your faith you have to be able
to speak it is fundamental and
again i go through that because i'm just
shocked by this i you're right to
assemble
i this was six seven months ago i spoke
to the new mexico republican party
in amarillo texas because they had to go
to texas to get freedom to assemble
because their democrat governor wouldn't
let him get together i mean in america
this kind of stuff is until a couple
weeks ago you couldn't even come to your
capitol to petition your member of
congress to redress your grievances
because nancy pelosi wouldn't let you in
but
all that's terrible but the biggest one
is when you can't talk when you can't
communicate and when last election
2020 presidential election when big tech
and big media colluded to keep the
american people in just the weeks right
before the election to keep the american
people from hearing the number one story
that they should have had access to at
that time the hunter biden story they
said oh no it's misinformation we had an
eyewitness
we had documents we had a laptop we had
the photos yeah it's like
but no no was misinformation
that's that's frightening and you're
that's why this is so important and we
have to get a remedy yes and i you know
so much of what you're saying has this
kind of
religious aspect to it i mean even down
to the word revival yeah or down to the
our our rights are you know the freedom
to practice i mean literally the freedom
to practice our faith when they shut
down the churches
just to sound a little pessimistic again
and i hope you
shut down my pessimism
america seems to be getting more secular
america seems to be getting more liberal
that's that's what the polls say
i agree with you i feel that there is
some deeper pulse in the american people
and maybe it's about to jump out but
looking at those numbers one do you
think that we can recover the american
tradition if we lose our faith if we
become more and more secular and and two
what does the revival
look like
well um no good questions uh i think
part of the reason that
we sort of summon the blame if if we're
not as um
uh christian focused as we should be
which i think is is accurate some of the
blame comes
to us you know i look at like
standards that we all have in our
personal life where maybe well okay we
need to improve and set that better
example so i think part of it is we got
to look we got to look at ourselves as
well
yeah i mean
exactly but i don't know i just
i mean you live in america you got to be
optimistic i i think it happens i think
i think it is
electing conservatives who will actually
go go fight for the things they told you
they were going to fight for i think
it's a focus on the constitution i think
it's a it's a real focus on on
people in office and the country
understanding better the rights that
we've enjoyed that were given to us
passed down to us under the first you
know that we have under the first
amendment um
i always say my my favorite
scripture verse i guess one reason i got
an optimistic attitude about my favorite
scripture verses is second timothy 4 7.
and paul's the old guy giving advice to
the young guy timothy and he tells them
to fight the good fight finish the
course keep the faith
and i always say i like that verse
because it's not a wimpy verse it's a
worse of of action and americans aren't
when people we're we're not timid people
we're americans right like what's the
goal let's go make it happen it's fight
finish keep so i think that's in us um
and
i just feel like we'll we'll do it and
it it manifests itself in
putting people in office um
who
who understand that and understand the
constitution and then probably also just
in communities where
get involved i think we're going to see
more people get involved whoever thought
we'd have the number of people showing
up at school board meetings right
and and people actually running for
school but that's got to be the worst
job in history right being on the school
board who would want that job you know
and who would have thought they'd be
talking about
critical race theory this bizarro
leftist academic lens from harvard law
school and and but
the american people see it they see the
effects of it they show up for this
terrible job you know who else loved
that verse that you quoted
ronald reagan oh really ronald reagan i
didn't even know that and it i i love i
mean this is i guess the point of the
book do what you said you would do is
that we need to do it it is all too
often i feel that at the point you know
these young conser
older conservatives
will they just want to dig up the corpse
of ronald reagan they want to reanimate
him somehow and have him fight all of
our battles for us and just say the same
old things that we said in the 80s and
try to go back to the glory days but no
we've got to fight he fought his battles
yeah we have to fight our battles too
politicians need to do what they said
that they will do yeah and not pass the
buck and i say truly without any
flattery you are one of the guys doing
it and it's a great inspiration you're
doing the hard work man you got
you go to college campuses and
god bless you man our security is not as
good yeah that's true the rotten
tomatoes go further but uh congressman
thank you very much
i hope that everyone goes and buys the
book do what you said you would do and
then congressman i hope that you are the
chairman of the house judiciary
committee and i hope you will do what
you said you will do and i'm i'm certain
and confident that you will thank you
thanks for having me on well thanks for
coming
[Music]
[Music]